tranche fine ou épaisse cette machine va
enfin couper court au débat l'yvelinois
eric lindeman est l'inventeur de cette
tranche est associée sont revisités plus
fonctionnel et 100% française l'idée lui
est venue devant sa télévision
j'étais séduit par ce produit est tout
de suite je me suis dit il fallait
vraiment que je crée un modèle avec une
inclinaison à 45° l'idée c'est vraiment
de créer quelque chose à 45° qu'ils
puissent découper facilement et surtout
tous les aliments parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les démons faire
simplement une trancheuse associés sont
en faire une deuxième nom mais l'idée
c'était vraiment de pouvoir développer
un produit qui soit vraiment utile au
quotidien
eric dit s'être inspiré de la guillotine
mais cette tranche s'avère beaucoup plus
convivial puisqu'elle coupe aussi les
carottes tomates citron et même les
pommes de terre
cette invention a connu un succès
tranchant auprès du jury du concours
lépine qui lui a décerné la médaille
d'argent alors que ce qu'on ressent
quand on sort ce diplôme tombe on est
plutôt content et satisfait on se dit
c'est c
c'est une belle réussite et c'est très
valorisant et c'est vrai que j'ai eu
beaucoup de commentaires très positifs
de personnes qui m'ont félicité je
pensais pas que l'impact serait aussi
important finalement son originalité
chaque modèle est fabriqué totalement à
la main deux entreprises du territoire
sont sollicités pour sa création une
pour le bois et l'autre pour la lame
eric commercialise ces machines au prix
de 89 euros